what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another song of ice and fire
chapter video
that's right folks we are jumping back
into the books as i said before
i will be making a video on each chapter
from the song of ice and fire book
series
since so many of you have been asking me
to do something like this for so long i
thought i should finally take your
advice
and let's be honest i needed to read
them again anyway because i can barely
remember
all the small details within these
massive novels
hopefully this will be a very fun
learning experience for not only myself
but also for those of you who have not
read the books i'm sure
most of you already heard about how
different the books are from the show
now you will finally see why so many
fans say the books are better
i hope these videos will give you a good
idea of what is happening in each of the
books
so go ahead and grab yourself a snack
because this is a good one
in this video we will be discussing the
first official chapter in a game of
thrones
now we will see the story unfold through
bran stark's eyes in his first
chapter of the book some of you might
not know this but what happens in bran
stark's chapter is actually what led to
george r martin creating this amazing
universe that we all know and love so
much
he basically said one day he was sitting
around and this specific scene
entered his head after writing it down
he thought about it over and over again
which eventually led to him writing
these giant novels that make up
this incredible story so for you this
creation began
back in 1991 and i know that's a while
ago
but i'm hoping you can remember for us
the scene or the image
that launched the series a song of ice
and fire
it was the it was the first chapter of
uh the novel game of thrones
not not the prologue which actually
appears first i wrote that
later but it was the uh the chapter
where they
brand viewpoint and they write out to
see the
the desert are beheaded and then they
find the direwolf pups in uh
in the summer obviously this had a major
impact on george so you can only imagine
how significant this chapter must be to
the overall series
it is often said that some of the
information in this first book
may reveal how it all ends if brian
stark does become the king of westeros
in the books as well
then it's no coincidence the story began
with his character
he will eventually gain access to all
the knowledge in the universe
as well as having a connection to every
major event that happens
let's go ahead and begin so we can see
how branstark ends up as one of the main
characters in a song of ice and fire
this chapter begins as bran stark is
getting ready to see his first execution
that's right branstar goes for a ride
along with ned stark's head removal
services
it actually says that bran is excited by
the thought of being able to see a man
get his head chopped off which i do find
interesting this goes to show you how
normal of a custom this was
in fact bran most likely felt left out
when his brothers would go with their
father to deliver the king's justice
but now that brain is seven years old he
is considered old enough to witness the
execution
if even only for a brief moment bran
stark feels like one of the men
now we begin to find out who this man
actually is and because of this
we learn some interesting details that
will set up things for later in the
story
you see rob stark thinks this man might
be a wildling
this reminds bran of some of old nan's
stories this is how we learn that mance
raider is the king beyond the wall
a character bran's brother john will
become very familiar with soon enough
bran also remembers old nan's stories
about wildling woman who would sleep
with the white walkers during the long
night
therefore creating these half human half
white walker children
this is brought to our attention on the
very first page of the very first
chapter i believe george rr martin is
giving us some significant details right
away
many of the starks do not believe her
stories but as we continue reading
through the books
you will begin to see there is some
solid evidence for what old nan
actually says the white walkers have
been given sacrifices for thousands of
years
and we will soon find out craster is
sacrificing his own sons to stay alive
out beyond the wall and later on in the
books
bran will remember another one of old
man's stories about a man known as the
night's king
who was also sacrificing his children to
the white walkers
now what makes this even more
fascinating is the fact that old man is
convinced that this night's king was a
member of house stark
so the groundwork for this revelation is
already being laid out in brian stark's
first chapter
that is most likely why we are
introduced to the starks immediately
after the white walkers
resurface after all these years they
have a connection that dates back to the
long night
this is very interesting because the
starks will become the main family that
attempts to defeat the white walkers
who may share their own blood when brain
stark sees the man his father has to
execute
he notices something that i wanted you
to remember from my last video
you see when this man is captured we
don't hear him say anything about the
white walkers like we did in the show
bran stark does hear them speaking about
something but he doesn't hear what is
said
so for all we know this man could be
anyone but bran notices something that
we were made aware of when we first
met gared bran notices the man has lost
his ears
and a finger to frostbite and he's
dressed in all black
now we know it's the same man from the
night's watch without anyone having to
say his name
i love when george reveals information
this way he lets the readers figure
things out on their own
instead of giving them all the answers
another thing i like about this chapter
is we learn exactly how
old some of the starks are they're
actually so much younger than they
appear to be in the show
as i said before bran stark is 7 years
old then we find out ned stark is only
35 years old
now it does say he has white hair in his
beard so he does look older than he
actually is
anyways now we are finally at the moment
of execution
like in the show theon greyjoy hands ned
stark his sword
ice it's a gigantic valyrian steel sword
that stands taller than ned's son
rob stark now another thing i find
interesting is what is said about the
sword
it says nothing holds an edge like
valerian steel
this sounds very familiar to what we
heard in the last chapter
when will saw the white walker's sword
he thought it looked sharper than any
razor he had ever seen
it's not a coincidence that we learn
about these magical swords and back to
back chapters
at the very beginning of the story we
meet the white walkers
and we find out they have a magical
sword that is different than any other
sword
but in the next chapter we find out how
stark also has a very magical sword that
is different than any other sword
this is obviously setting up the
inevitable fight between members of
house stark and the white walkers
these magical swords will eventually
clash and it will be glorious
i also think it's very interesting that
the starks call their sword ice
you will learn in the books that the
name ice dates back to the age of heroes
most likely during the long night the
sword that ned stark has is only 400
years old but the starks have been
naming their house sword ice for
thousands of years
and it makes me wonder why they started
to do that i believe it has a connection
to the white walkers
and their ultimate defeat during the
long night you see
the stark's house was founded roughly 8
000 years ago
around the same exact time that
winterfell was built right after the
long night ended
now i have made several videos about
this over the years but i think how
stark was set up in winterfell
after they defeated the white walkers in
that location
hence the name winterfell i believe that
is where the night king
or the king of winter fell i think this
is when the starks begun to name their
sword ice
symbolizing their victory over the white
walkers
even though they won they always knew
they might come back
so that's when they started warning
everyone that winter is coming
a phrase that later became their house
words afterwards the white walkers fled
into the north
then they built the wall to make sure
they could never come back south
however if the white walker somehow made
it through the wall
then winterfell would be the second line
of defense this is exactly why
i always said the final battle against
the night king what happened in
winterfell
as it did 8 000 years ago like i said
before
there is a good reason why the starks
get their introduction
directly after the white walkers
resurfaced in the story
it's all connected folks now i do have
additional evidence for this but i don't
want to get into all of it right now
i will discuss it further as other
evidence is revealed throughout the
chapters
in fact i might even release a video
about all the different connections
between hal stark and the white walkers
i might even release that video in a few
days before i do another chapter video
that way you know exactly what i mean
whenever i reference these connections
from here on out
but let's move on now we are moments
away from the execution this is when we
find out who the king of the seven
kingdoms is
one ned stark says
in the name of robert of the house
baratheon the first of his name
don't look away king of the animals in
the first father will know if you do
lord of the seven kingdoms and protector
of the realm
i eddard the house stark
lord of winterfell and warden of the
north
sentence you to die since ned stark is
the warden of the north
he is responsible for delivering the
king's justice
in this region of westeros ned stark is
the head of the house that i believe
this story is centered around
so it's very important that we meet all
of its members very early on
in this series here is also when we meet
jon snow
arguably one of the most important
members of house stark
now although this is bran's chapter it
does give us some interesting details
about jon snow
who is only 14 years old at the
beginning of the
story so ned stark executes the deserter
from the night's watch with one single
stroke of his sword
as they are heading back to winterfell
rob and john have a discussion about the
man who was just executed
rob says the deserter died bravely
whereas
john says no this one was dead of fear
you could see it in his eyes then it
says john's eyes were a gray
so dark they seemed almost black but
there was little they did not see
remember this line about jon's eyes for
later i will mention it again
at the end of the chapter it also says
jon was slender
where rob was muscular dark where rob
was fair
graceful and quick where his
half-brother was strong and fast
then john and rob begin to erase their
horses back
and it mentions one other interesting
thing about jon that i want you to
remember for later
it says when they begin to race rob was
laughing
but john was silent and intent i believe
these details about jon are a direct
connection to his direwolf ghost
who he will find at the end of the
chapter i will explain what i mean once
we get there
now we get to one of my favorite moments
from the scene when bran
and his father discuss the execution
even if you haven't read the books i'm
sure you will remember this from the
show
this is when bran said the ned robb says
the man died bravely
but jon says he was afraid this makes
bran
think and ask can a man be brave even if
he's afraid
ned says that is the only time a man can
be brave
then ned says do you understand why i
did it
bran thinks it might be because the man
was a wildling and wildlings are known
for kidnapping women
and selling them to the others or the
white walkers
ned says the man was an oath breaker a
deserter from the night's watch
no man is more dangerous the deserter
knows his life is forfeit if he is taken
so he will not flinch from any crime no
matter how vile
however this is not why ned is asking
bran the question
he isn't asking why the man should die
but why ned has to be the one to see it
through
ned says our way is the old way if you
would take a man's life
you owe it to him to look into his eyes
and hear his final words
and if you cannot bear to do that then
perhaps the man does not deserve to die
a man who hides behind executioners soon
forgets what death is
i love how ned takes a moment to drop
some knowledge on his son
by making sure he understands why he had
to execute the man
brain will need to take that lesson with
him because one day he might have to do
the same thing
now although he does sometimes make
mistakes i think this does show that ned
stark is a good father overall
he appears to be an honest man who is
also lawful
who likes to carry out each and every
action with honor and integrity
but as the story begins to unfold we
will see that ned will have to make some
very hard decisions that go against his
own code
in order to save his loved ones we will
also begin to see that most of ned's
beliefs are in his children as well
in a story that is full of greed
corruption and backstabbings
the starks will become one of the
families we will look to
for some hope now let's move on to the
final scene of the chapter
as i said before this was the first
image that came to george rr martin
when he began writing a song of ice and
fire this is when they find the
direwolves in the late summer snows
as ned and bran are having their
discussion john appears on the crest of
the hill before them he yells for them
to follow him
he says hurry up and see what rob has
found
ned bran and jory arrive on scene
where the snows are actually very deep
it says
rob is knee-deep in the snow as he is
standing there holding something
in his arms when they all see what it is
they're actually kind of afraid
it's not like you stumble across a
direwolf every day
these animals are massive which i think
the show did a decent job at getting
that across
the dead direwolf that's lying in the
snow is so big
it says it's even bigger than the pony
that bran is riding on
in this scene it was double the size of
any of the hounds at winterfell
which is crazy this is when we learned
that direwolves have not been seen south
of the wall in hundreds of years
in the books to follow we will begin to
see that the starks finding these dire
wolves was no accident
as jon snow says the stark children were
meant to have them
they are a gift from the old gods but
more specifically
the children of the forest and
bloodraven they sent these dire wolves
to keep them
safe and help them on their journeys
throughout the story
they are the sigil of the stark's house
after all each of the direwolves seem to
have a deeper connection with their
owner
some would even say the names given to
the dire wolves foreshadow the future of
the stark children
either way it's safe to say that starks
do have a very special bond with their
direwolves
i'm not only referring to loyalty either
they have a magical bond that allows
them to enter the mind of their animal
and see through its eyes now in the
television show we only saw bran stark
have that ability
but in the books you will learn that
more than one stark can do this but i
don't want to start diving into all of
that just yet
we have so much more to unfold i will
discuss all of that further as some of
the future chapters begin to reveal the
evidence laid out for this
so now we are at the moment in which ned
says do you know what killed this animal
robb actually gets excited here because
he already knows the answer
he did notice there was something stuck
in its throat this is when ned kneels
down
and yanks out a foot of shattered antler
then holds it up for all to see
a sudden silence falls over the crowd
the men look at the antler uneasily
and no one dared to speak even bran
could sense their fear
though he did not understand they
believe this is a bad sign
or omen this image alone has many
different interpretations
you can almost understand why the starks
would feel so uneasy about it
the direwolf is the sigil of their house
now they find a dead one
that should not even be south of the
wall in the first place they might fear
this symbolizes the future of their own
house
but then there is added layer to it
because the direwolf was killed by a
stag
which happens to be the sigil of house
baratheon
since both animals died maybe it
symbolizes how stark and house baratheon
killing each other
either way ned stark has to be thinking
someone better bring me my brown pants
almost everyone in the scene wants to
leave immediately
even ned doesn't think they should be
taking the direwolves home
but coincidentally enough it's the stark
children who say otherwise
maybe they are already starting to feel
a connection to the direwolves
rob stark gets mad at theon for wanting
to kill them
bran almost cries when he thinks they
will have to leave them behind
and of course it's jon who convinces ned
to allow them to take them home
jon points out there are five of them
three male
and two female which lines up exactly
with the stark children
jon snow may know nothing but even he
could see the starks were meant to have
them
he knew this was no accident which is
interesting because earlier in the
chapter
bran even says there was little that
john's eyes did not see
what makes it even more interesting is
what bray notices when jon finds ghost
you see john doesn't find ghost as fast
as he did in the show
they are actually already leaving and
it's when they're halfway across the
bridge that jon hears something in the
distance
this causes him to stop and jon says
don't you hear
it bran hears the wind in the trees and
the horse's hooves on the iron wood
planks
but jon was listening to something else
john swings his horse around
and races back across the bridge
everyone watches john dismount
where the mother direwolf was laying
dead in the snow they watch him as he
kneels down
and a moment later he was riding back
only now he was smiling
he must have crawled away from the
others john said
now john found ghost his fur was white
where the rest of the litter was gray
his eyes were as red as the blood of the
ragged man who died this morning
bran thought it was curious that this
direwolf alone would have opened its
eyes
while the others were still blind in
albino
theon greyjoy says this one will die
even faster than the others
john says i think not this one belongs
to me
alright so there is a lot of fascinating
things to unpack right here
first i want to mention some of the
similarities between jon and ghost
here it says his fur is white where the
rest of the litter was gray
this shows how ghost stands out from the
rest similar to john
who as we all know is not actually ned's
son
jon is the outcast of the bunch just
like ghost
also brain said there was little john's
eyes did not see
and like we learned here ghost already
had his eyes open
whereas the rest of the litter was still
blind this makes you wonder how much of
a connection jon and ghost already had
maybe jon was already inside the mind of
ghost without even knowing it
i mean he did somehow hear him after all
when it is said that ghost is silent
unlike the other direwolves ghost does
not bark and he moves silently on his
feet
so how did jon hear him did they already
have a magical bond
most likely or maybe something else was
happening here
i think something very special was
happening when jon found
ghost something that i will not easily
be able to explain
in this video i actually already made a
video about the reason i think jon was
able to find ghosts the way that he did
i think you will find it to be very
interesting if you haven't seen it
already
i might release that video again this
week while i'm working on the next
chapter video
but we shall see also if you remember
earlier in the chapter we hear about
rob and john racing on their horses it
said that rob was laughing
where jon was silent and intent like i
said a second ago
ghost is also known for being very
silent so i think this is another
similarity between jon and ghost
they both move silently also when it
mentions ghost having his eyes open
first
this may symbolize jon opening his eyes
first
robb said the deserter died bravely but
jon knew otherwise
he knew the man was afraid of something
we are also told that bastards have to
grow up faster than the other children
this may also represent that jon has
some level of maturity before the other
children
his eyes are already open to the world
around him
in fact john even says a bastard has to
learn to notice things
to read the truth that people hide
behind their eyes so i think this lines
up really well with ghost already having
his eyes open
or at least it makes sense to me one
other thing i want to mention is what
theon greyjoy said about ghost
he said an albino this one will die even
faster than the others
then jon says i think not this one
belongs to me
john is absolutely right as we all know
ghost will not be the first one to die
in fact i could even make an argument
that ghost is more important than all
the other direwolves
he finds the white hand out beyond the
wall he alerts
jon when the white is attacking lore
commander mormont
ghost is the one that finds the
dragonglass and most likely the horn of
winter out beyond the wall as well
and not to mention jon will most likely
use ghost as a vessel
to keep his mind alive as his body is
bleeding out
this will help jon significantly during
his resurrection
so that jon can go on and be
instrumental in the defeat of the white
walkers
but we shall see let me know your
thoughts on this chapter
in my opinion this one sets up so many
things for the future of the series
as i said before i may release a video
this week about the connection between
the starks and the white walkers
as well as the connection between jon
and ghost
i have already made some videos where i
laid out all the evidence so i may
update those then release them to help
add some context to the things i
mentioned
in the first two chapter videos also i
want to mention that i have made some
new shirts that are on sale right now
if you are interested in grabbing one of
these there will be a link down below
if you do buy one make sure you send me
an email of a photo of you wearing the
shirt
that way i can add it to one of my
videos anyways i want to thank everyone
for stopping by to watch the video
as always i really appreciate that
hopefully
you all come back to watch the next one
have a great day
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
so
you